I'm here with Walter Isaacson and what
are we about to talk about we're talking
about the Declaration of Independence
which happens as it says at top on July
4th 1776 but we have to remember is that
for more than a year since April of 1775
there had been a lot of fighting going
on there was a revolution happening but
up until this point the fighting was
mainly against what they considered to
be the acts of parliament and
Parliament's ministers and taxing the
colonies and finally with this document
they decide they're going to become the
American colonies are going to become
free and independent a separate country
which means rebelling against the king
himself George the third and this is
George the third right all of his
regality but you know up until they met
in Congress you know with the
Continental Congress gathering
themselves together they pretended at
least to respect George the third and
they were blaming everything on the
British Parliament but it was a pretty
difficult thing to decide you were going
to overthrow the king himself and just
to be clear you know these this is
Continental Congress it's easy now for
us in hindsight to make it it seems like
a very official thing but this was
really a it was a rebel Congress it was
it wasn't sanctioned in any way by kind
of the formal government by the
government of Great Britain right and as
you see it says the 13 United States of
America this is the first time they
really start using the phrase United
States of America they want really a
country yet they were 13 different
colonies and not all of them wanted to
come to this Continental Congress
getting them all together was quite
difficult they do so partly to help
George Washington's troops get funded
because there's they've started the
skirmishes up in Lexington and Concord
in Massachusetts but by 1776 George
Washington has a real army and they have
to fund him and eventually they'd figure
out will this Congress ought to decide
are we really having a revolution are we
trying to break away from the king
himself and the answer here is yes
and so this
is the beginning of the Declaration of
Independence and these three fellows on
the right-hand side look very familiar
they're on the committee that the
Congress appoints to draft the
Declaration actually the five people on
the committee but these are of course
the three most important Thomas
Jefferson only 33 years old by far the
youngest person on the committee and
he's chosen to write the first draft
then Benjamin Franklin who is a mentor
of Jefferson's a printer from
Philadelphia
Franklin had just been spending you know
the past two decades almost going back
and forth to England to try to prevent a
revolution and then John Adams the very
passionate sage from the state of
Massachusetts who was the one who was
most in favor of revolution in fact when
Franklin comes back to Philadelphia in
early 1776 after having tried to hold
Britain in America together most of
these people didn't know whether he
would be on the side of revolution or
not in fact his own son William Franklin
is at this time of this Declaration the
royal governor of New Jersey and is
staying loyal to King George and and
just to once again emphasize the context
the royal governor of New Jersey this
wasn't like the governor of New Jersey
we imagine now wasn't elected by them
you know it was appointed by the king he
was a royal governor and you know
Franklin was proud of his son but they
have this incredible split starting in
1776 will William Franklin remains loyal
to the crown and loyal to King George
the 3rd who had made him governor of New
Jersey now one thing that you would
mentioned a few seconds ago that I think
is surprising is when you mentioned that
Jefferson was 33 years old
when he wrote the Declaration of
Independence how normal was that you
know back then it seemed like people did
like its mature faster and but but he
was still perceived as a fairly young
person yes they all love to be thinking
of themselves as young rebels too in
fact Jefferson I think it's a second
youngest person in the Continental
Congress but there was a third person
who lied about his age to pretend to be
younger and actually wasn't but
Jefferson was a good war
Smith he was from Virginia and it was
very important of this person from
Franklin from Pennsylvania and Adams
from Massachusetts to make sure we got
Virginia and because Virginia you know
there was a chance it would remain loyal
and large wealthy a large wealthy land
owning colony and so getting the
Virginians in and there were very strong
rebels from Virginia it was you know the
leaves of Virginia as well as Jefferson
were in favor of declaring independence
so they decide they want to make sure
that Jefferson gets to write the first
draft interesting and so this what we
see here this is the this is the final
text this is the official declaration of
an entire future videos we can talk
about previous drafts right they went
through five drafts to get to this draft
and this is the one that they do after
unanimously all 13 colonies now call the
13 United States and this document
declare this to be the cause of the
colonies and what you can see in the
first paragraph is they have to explain
why are we writing this document and
they say well if you're going to have a
revolution if you're going to dissolve
the political bands which have connected
you with another state then the laws of
nature and of nature's God entitle them
a decent respect this is this is the
equal station they get because of nature
and nature's God it's a pretty
interesting phrase let's let's read the
whole thing yeah when in the course of
human events it becomes necessary for
one people to dissolve the political
bands is what you're talking about which
have connected them with another and to
assume among the powers of the earth the
separate and equal station which the
laws of nature and of nature's God
entitle them what they're saying right
there is that the laws of nature and the
fact that nature's God created us all
equally means that one set of people
don't have to be subservient to or
occupied by or colonies of another set
of people they want to be free and
independent and it's interesting that
they use the phrase laws of nature and
Nate
God because this is sort of the
beginning of the enlightenment well
we're supposed to understand that nature
gives us our rights and reasons John
Locke the great British philosopher
believed in the laws of nature and these
were deists they kind of were religious
a bit but they didn't subscribe to any
particular religious dogma and so they
just talked about nature's God allowing
us all to be free and equal right and a
decent respect to the opinions of
mankind requires that they should
declare the causes which impel them to
the separation that's what they're
really just saying what they're saying
is we care about the rest of you think
and by the way it's directed at one
particular people the French because
we're not going to win this revolution
in the United States unless the French
help support us the French by the way
were already at war with the British and
there's been a long set of Wars
throughout the 18th century well France
and Britain were fighting each other so
this document is particularly aimed at
saying to the French you've been
fighting Britain for a long time so we
have a decent respect for all the
opinions of mankind but yours in
particular and we're going to tell you
why we're fighting this and of course in
France at the time this notion of
liberty equality fraternity that's
bubbling up as well so the document is
to try to persuade other nations please
support us we're explaining why we're
having this revolution and that's I
think important to remember for someone
in you know 21st century America it's
obviously a major world power now the
major world power but back then this was
a little colony it's kind of a sideshow
right right and it's important for us to
remember now too that whenever we do
something whenever we get involved in
the world we should have a decent
respect to the opinions of mankind
that's how we started as a nation saying
when we do something we're going to be
open we're going to be honest we're
going explain to you why